за 20 особисту історію конституції України
до основного закону в носом та зміни
сестра зив видів яких нині точити
Анабель ж дискусій можна розділити на
три головнина премії децентралізація
територіальні громади ми цим трьом це
біляші повного дружини засіки з диво
розбудив і фінанси в потрібна проблема і
стрибати для спекуляції пункту проекту
зимовим до конституції із частотою всього
запливи прагне його ви сама видування
в україн їх районах донецького це
луганської області та влада заповнюють
цінного означає їм і треба не особливо його до
статусу для донбас у друга проблема
польова ще децентралізація стала
за ручну мінських у рік ви до нас шиви
міг ще до конституційних змін
суті зустрічає плавна вирок
процес теж голосування охуєти або
ставити узо тільки не ставить ви до неї
зубів yasin сепаратистськими лідерами так
званих днр і лнр
крим до нової редакції конституції мають
на світ замість зради доповнення для
закріплення прав кримських татар на саму
ви значенням в темно будинок кубок набряк
експертів дістати не було чи пскова ти
закон про право курячих народів в Україні
від живої поправки до конституції
україни ми могли б безміни чинні
конституції автономної республіки крим
а потім травня проголосувати і кримський
парламент все за нинішніх умов неможливо
суду в реформа зимин була і
правосуддя в зростанні точно за твердині
верховну раду їм у погана митарі
формувати із задоволенням україни
засіки чебуреки політичні органи
витрачав і вплив на суді
так і права на керування значать і
шпалери дзвенять і судді аж до вати суду на
арешт пройдуть і вигляд президента і
парламенту донного створені віднімай у ради
правосуддя нас промислові суддів
підтвердити або ganis походження своїх
солодким прикладом може бути і підставою
для і звели мене титанчик про статус
незмінні в голосі правосуддя закон про
гострий сад на будучи насті в житті в
ким реальних тіла не реформ це змін
засудивши затягнути зі стінок або коротким